even more overtime
Sasha asks congressman I say a study
came out this week showing that Congress
got 25% richer during the recession and
200 members of Congress are millionaires
how are we supposed to trust Congress to
protect the 99 percent if they're in the
1 percent I think the we also have some
members of Congress with negative net
worth and that doesn't make them more
trustworthy the fact is that most
members of Congress are out of business
they are in fact static investors and
the most conservative investments
actually did better than great waging in
the stock market owning more speculative
commodities that's one of the sad things
I mean Joe Biden and plenty of other
people had increases for that reason the
question you really have to ask is why
is it there are so many people who go to
Congress and go to the Senate who never
made money before they got there you
know some of them make money well
they're there that's a separate problem
but it is sort of amazing to me every
time I meet somebody who's done well in
their career really well a doctor even a
lawyer or in fact a businessman I go wow
this is what everyone should be you need
the competition to become a congressman
should be huge
in fact sometimes the standards are too
low and you do end up with people for
whom it's the best job they've why did a
guy like you who is very wealthy I mean
you did very well in the private sector
I got very lucky at least a few look I
mean my wife's in the audience I mean
we're we're not no I'm not a communist
I'm a capitalist I believe in capitalism
with regulation more than we have and
you want to get paid for your residuals
and I want to get paid for my residuals
and I'm glad we learned to tell jokes
yeah but I mean why does a guy who's
worth all that money and doesn't need to
work what do you why why you in the
Congress why do you why do you go there
because it's got to be a lot of bit not
fun it's it's a simple answer at some
point you ask what it is you can do that
makes your contribution to the time you
spend on earth worthwhile and I'm not a
bible-thumper I don't spend a lot of
time talking about the life after but I
do ask the question of am I doing
something worthwhile he's
it's just making more money I was lucky
I got to make a lot of money what do you
do next
then why does it feel like everybody is
just constantly running for re-election
and that people are no longer
legislating because it's the noble thing
to do and they want to steer the country
into the right direction well first of
all to a certain extent you messed about
constitutional changes I'd give members
of the House a four-year term I really
think that you should be picking all you
members of the house and your president
at the same time every four years and
first of all it would mean that the
president and the Congress would have
that next two years not to be running
and it would be unseemly for them to run
and that would help a lot because right
now as soon as the president gets
reelected or elected the first thing he
does is he tries to help his own party
in the mid term so even if he's not
running he's running for his party none
of it ever ends and then it's a
perpetual election and and that is one
of the problems without an election you
lose the advantage of accountability to
the people if you have them too often
you never get to where you do what you
were supposed to do for which they
wanted to hold you accountable Tunisia
has been a democracy for like a week
they already do it better than we do but
seriously they you know they most
they're only trying to get french
tourists back remember their economy is
very simple okay what is the status of
the Forgotten 15 uh-huh yeah we were
gonna talk about this jobs bills and
would they actually create jobs if
passed now if you don't know what this
is this is pretty inside baseball stuff
but Obama's handful it to explain it
here tonight Wow jobs.gop.gov okay you
can get your own hello I don't want a
thanks for asking lost in the weeds but
Obama's of course going around the
country promoting his jobs bill which
most independent economists say would
create jobs the Republican answer is
what about the Forgotten 15 what about
the jobs bills we've already proposed
well I looked at what these jobs bills
are there are mostly giveaways to
industry to pollute as if polluting more
would somehow cause jobs I really think
this is a false dynamic that you have
created here that if you somehow
get rid of the EPA I mean here at Time
magazine this week the deregulation myth
ignore the rhetoric nations with more
rules grow faster regulations are not
what is killing jobs do you believe that
regulatory uncertainty is killing the
investment class it is killing people
who want to make an investment but
they're playing on a set of rules that
keep changing the the bill some of the
Forgotten 15 are about making it harder
to pass new regulations I know of no one
who's saying let's roll back clean air
or clean water they are starting to say
well wait a second here why is it we
can't say in time in bad times let's not
endlessly try to make quantum leaps in
new things that quite frankly we do make
it harder for me I know I know people
who are asking for that you may not know
them but you work with them which is odd
because I don't work with them but well
just here the people who are for you
know Michele Bachmann doesn't show up to
do okay okay the The Forgotten 15 bills
the clean water cooperation federalism
Act
let's States deregulate water pollution
should be called the dirty water act
jobs and any energy permitting act
neuters all EPA rules related to the
Clean Air Act how come you don't know
these people these are the people in
Congress who are pushing these well see
see congressman the thing is the thing
about that there are it is probably fair
to say that the federal government at
this point is cumbersome and complex
that small business which creates
two-thirds of the jobs in this country
probably needs to be deregulated to some
degree but for some reason that seems to
open the door to a notion in this
country that there should be no
government at all which is absurd when
you deconstruct that type of argument in
front of a joint session and says we've
got 500 regulations we should get rid of
now the president he did he said it in a
joint session yeah the fact is there's a
lot of Republican things that he just
walked back ozone regulations this is
someone that has has
working inside the White House he walked
that new regulation he didn't he did not
rollback regulation their presidential
terms he's actually deregulated less
than President Bush did regulated less
signed less new regulations that the
whole point though about America's
competitiveness is give the business
community as much certainty going
forward which by the way does not mean
deregulate it means stop endlessly say
we got to have a new regulation for
everything but this we have a lot of new
regulations from Krista from the
dodd-frank that are still being rolled
out and banks are seeing changes that
they're being told about on a weekly or
monthly basis but this time magazine
this week on this very it just came out
today says the United States is the
fourth easiest place in the world to do
business only Singapore and Hong Kong
and New Zealand are easier have less
regulation than we do and it goes on to
say that a lot of these countries that
have more regulation actually do better
grow faster China is growing faster has
a lot more regulation Brazil Argentina
India this country you can put in all
brand new equipment to make sure your
sawmill making lumber doesn't put out
one bit of sawdust and you can still be
fined if the trucks driving in driving
on a dirt road and throw up dust we have
a number of areas in which we've let
regulatory excess I'm sure that in your
long the fact is if the president wants
to lead he doesn't have to accept the
ar-15 what he has to do is engage in a
process of defining those items which if
we stopped having them an undefined made
some if you will a regulatory freeze not
you've roll back regulations but tell
people for the next five years it's
going to be a little harder to pass a
new regulation because we want them to
make investments and we don't want them
looking over the shoulder for what's
going to change first White House that
has taken the position that you need to
examine the impact on job creation and
the business community when you enact
new regulation so I don't understand how
you can say that they'd be PA
operation especially when the data
around job-killing regulations doesn't
exist I mean most of the time when you
have these like statistics about 13,000
jobs will be lost there's no there's no
follow-up data there there's very few
studies the EPA the the amendments to
the Clean Air Act that the EPA
instituted we're supposed to cost 7.5
billion dollars and result in the loss
of 10 thousands tens of thousands of
jobs at the end of the day cost 1
billion dollars and were net job
creators so this myth that is out there
of like regulations and clean water
equal you know job killers is just a
false
I'll give you data we spent 350 million
dollars
Department of Labor to do training on
green jobs and according to their own
figures we created for 350 million
dollars 1,000 net new jobs that means
jobs that lasted one year or more we
created 8,000 but a year later there's
only one thousand included in that green
jobs that we created is anybody who
drove a darn bus a diesel bus qualifies
under the rules sometimes the way we
define success is so dumbed down in
government that we can't possibly fail
not that 350 million for 1,000 jobs
exactly good the truth is I agree with
the president much more than he
understands my problem is when we sit
down in Congress and say the president
said this in front of a joint session
now let's go to work on it you have
Nancy Pelosi saying we're not even gonna
have a discussion because you guys just
want dirty water I won't want dirty
water but I do want to have people
making investments that create net new
jobs in the private sector I think we
can get there that the failure of
leadership of this president is he
hasn't made sure we got there that's why
Mitt Romney what I'm hoping for him is
he does bring us together he does apply
does don't leadership anybody can do it
it's men thank you I mean I mean it's
late here one last question and then
I'll let you go Alicia Hernandez says
how does the panel feel about Ann
Coulter's comment on black Republicans
being better she said our blacks are
better than your blacks that's what you
said about I guess it was the Herman
cane thing that made her say that there
blacks are bananas she's talking about
Michael Steele she's talking about
Herman Cain is there another Clarence
Thomas
so Michael Steele Herman Cain Clarence
Thomas I I would take our blacks I
really I would I think our black be
better I gotta I gotta say
what I high-five you well I think is
disturbing is that she's still figuring
out which of the best blacks I used to
do that a plantation yeah by the way
she's since an is so worried about
blacks there is one change I would have
made to the Constitution it was to
remove article four section 2 Clause 3
of the Constitution which is the
provision that provides for the recovery
of runaway slaves which was never taken
out and never a minute and is still
there so insha as this for maybe an will
even support that and maybe her blacks
will support it too